the first special forces operation
detachment delta
or more commonly referred to as delta
force is an elite special mission unit
of the united states army the unit is
tasked with specialized missions
involving hostage rescue
and counter-terrorism as well as special
reconnaissance against high-value
targets
delta force is among the us military's
primary tier 1
special mission units tasked with
performing the most complex
classified and dangerous missions
delta force was formed after a number of
terrorist incidents that occurred during
the 1970s
although military and government
officials had been discussing this type
of unit since the early 60s
eventually it was agreed that the us
army needed units of highly adaptable
and completely autonomous teams who were
equipped with a wide range of skills for
direct action
and counter-terrorism missions delta
force was officially established
on the 19th of november 1977.
its primary goal is a counter-terrorist
unit specifically directed to kill
or capture high-value targets or
dismantle terrorist cells
but the unit is extremely flexible and
can also engage in direct action
missions
hostage rescues and covert assignments
the majority of operations assigned to
delta are classified
and most may never be known to the
public
applicants to delta force must be male
have at least two and a half years of
service
remaining in their enlistment be 21
years or older and score high enough
on the armed services vocational
aptitude battery a timed multi-aptitude
test
before they are able to attend the
initial briefing to even be considered
candidates must also be trained in
military parachuting and qualified to
participate
in airborne missions most importantly
they must be eligible for high-level
security clearance
and have not been convicted by
court-martial or have any disciplinary
action noted in their official military
personnel file
the following selection would often only
see 10 to 12 percent of applicants
completing the course after the
reactivation of team rainbow in 2015
one delta force operator was recruited
to bring their skills and expertise to
assist in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale this operator was
named
[Music]
[Music]
maverick
i was trapped for a long time
lived and seen things you couldn't
imagine
now i see things in a different light
here thorne code named maverick is an
attacking operator
in team rainbow maverick grew up in
boston massachusetts
and was part of a multilingual family
his parents were kind and loving but
they were often very strict
and decidably inflexible when it came to
presenting him with the outside
experiences away from the family
a naturally gifted child his parents
pushed him to be better
to aim higher and provided him with an
almost overwhelming magnitude of
different sensory experiences
that most kids his own age would have
struggled with
it's fair to say that he thrived in this
type of environment through being able
to break things down around him and
group them into manageable chunks
he was able to thrive and grow at a pace
that left the other kids behind
this resulted in maturity and growth
beyond his years and this was shown in
intelligence tests
scoring highly and in the top two
percent among kids his own age
after high school he enlisted with the
us army and quickly rose through the
ranks
although he was exposed to a number of
experiences at home he had very few
opportunities to explore outside of his
own backyard
and this is one of the driving factors
that led him to join the army
where he could experience the world in a
way he was unable to growing up he
learned dari and became an intelligence
officer
serving in kabul the capital of
afghanistan and it was during this time
that a number of foreign reporters
tourists and criminals were also
flocking into the city
maverick was well known in the
underground club scene and especially
among the locals as a proficient ukashi
player
which is a central asian sport where
horse-mounted players attempt to place a
goat
or calf carcass in a goal
eventually maverick was invited into
delta force as a regional specialist
his role was to remain in the country
gathering intel building networks
establishing safe houses and tracking
hostiles
but as the situation in afghanistan
started to deteriorate
a lot of his time was spent keeping an
eye on americans and helping the locals
to escape the growing violence
even right from the start merrick knew
that the period of peace would
eventually end
he could see the injection of people
coming from outside the country
especially westerners
flooding in drinking at restaurants and
partying in the underground clubs
he saw what was coming long before
anyone else
insurgent groups could see that the
westerners were easy targets in these
situations
it was only a matter of time before they
acted on it
and then somewhere along the way while
maverick was investigating a missing
reporter
delta force completely lost contact with
him
two years pass before he is seen again
unexpectedly
he was discovered by specialist knock
and with him he had enough intel to
dismantle a major insurgency operation
working in the area
understandably there was still a number
of questions floating around about his
abrupt disappearance
but regardless he was exonerated and his
evidence sealed
it was the success of missions like
these that first gained in the attention
of six a legend among intelligence
operatives
maverick is known as the agent who went
native
his intellect an intimidating level of
skill when it comes to reading others
make him somewhat difficult person to
interact with however
bringing up kabul or buskashi will
quickly bring him out of his shell
on the other hand maverick is
exceptionally empathetic that comes from
his strong
ability to watch listen and dissect
situations
people often openly confide in them
which is a skill that likely assisted
him in his survival while operating in
kabul
information around maverick's
disappearance tells the story of a
horrific ordeal
but the experience and the scars that
came with it only brought him closer to
afghanistan
he has a tattoo on his left arm as a
reminder of the time he spent there
although maverick's mind and body is
with team rainbow his heart is very
obviously still in kabul
maverick's gadget is a diy blue torch
called suri
siri can breach any surface including
reinforced walls and hatches
though it requires a steady hand in a
knowledge of the environment to create
small holes and lines of sight
the torch makes almost no sound but will
rapidly deplete fuel supplies
regardless the high precision of this
tool makes it useful in a variety of
situations
without relying on digital technology
i love seeing these backstories with the
other operators crossover
i'm actually thinking of putting
together a video on the relationships
between each specialist
it could be interesting and probably
super difficult to follow
i'll think about it for now i think i'm
going to go see if there are any local
new zealand buskashi clubs around
i'm very intrigued by this sport
otherwise thank you very much for
watching i hope you've enjoyed it
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
so
you